veamos si podemos encontrar el límite
cuando x tiende a infinito
de x entre x cuadrada menos 1 y como
siempre pausa el vídeo y ver si puedes
encontrarlo por tu cuenta
bueno hay un par de formas para trabajar
este problema una es simplemente dar una
razón del por qué llegamos a esa
respuesta y decir mira este numerador de
aquí
de x para oscilar todo el tiempo entre
menos uno y uno así que déjame
escribirlo el coseno de x es por una
parte siempre mayor o igual que menos 1
es decir menos 1 es menor o igual que el
coste de x que a su vez es menor o igual
que 1 entonces este numerador lo único
que hace aquí sposi lar entre menos uno
y uno mientras x se incrementa y ahora
el denominador bueno tenemos x cuadrada
menos 1 así que el numerador será cada
vez más y más y más grande por esta x
cuadrada este valor será muy muy muy muy
grande
mientras x incremente entonces algo que
está acotado entre menos uno y uno
dividido entre algo que es infinitamente
grande a que se va a aproximar bueno
esto se va a aproximar a cero y así
llegamos a la respuesta bueno esa es una
forma de trabajarlo otra forma va a ser
llegar al mismo argumento pero
trabajarlo de una manera un poco más
matemática porque como sabemos el coche
no está acotado entonces podemos decir y
déjame escribirlo aquí que el coche no
de x / x cuadrada menos 1 y bueno esto
que acabo de escribir va a ser menor o
igual y primero observa que lo más que
puede valer este numerador el coste no
de que es lo más que puede valer es 1
entonces esto es menor o igual que 1 / x
cuadrada menos 1 y por otra parte esto
será mayor o igual y ahora recuerda que
lo menos que puede valer el coseno de x
este numerador es menos uno entonces
menos uno entre x cuadrada menos uno va
a ser menor o igual
en esta expresión que tengo aquí y una
vez más estoy diciendo que coseno de x
lo más que puede valer es un hombre y lo
menos que puede valer es menos 1 y esto
va a ser cierto para toda x entonces
podemos decir que el límite cuando x
tiende a infinito de esta primera
expresión va a ser menor o igual que el
límite cuando extiende infinito lejos de
lo que buscamos y esto a su vez va a ser
menor o igual que el límite cuando
extiende infinito de esta segunda
expresión de 1 entre ex cuadrada menos 1
y esto es cierto para todas x ahora
puedes hacer el siguiente argumento a
esta primera expresión le pasa lo
siguiente lo de arriba es una constante
y los de abajo tiende a infinito
entonces esto de aquí va a tender a cero
cuando x tiende a infinito y entonces me
quedaría que 0 es menor o igual que el
límite cuando x tiende a infinito de
coseno de x / x cuadrada menos uno que
es justo lo que buscamos
esto a su vez va a ser menor o igual y
observa que usted también va a ser cero
tenemos un numerador constante y un
denominador no acotado que tiende a
infinito y entonces este de aquí también
va a ser cero entonces el límite que
buscamos tiene que estar entre 0 y 0 es
decir 0 es menor o igual que el límite
que buscamos que es menor o igual que 0
y entonces este de aquí este límite que
buscamos tiene que ser cero y ya
acabamos